now we have some mvps of the team coco
world
you know her as the co-host of conan
o'brien needs a friend
sotomo session is here you know him from
blackish
you know him from this very funny
special on netflix called cold hearted
which
i personally i wanted that name but you
know he got it before me
and he's got a new special slash
non-special out
that i want to talk to him about please
welcome sodom obsession
and dion cole thank you both for being
here hey leon
what's up family how's everybody we're
good
donna what is that behind you sana
pancho
no i don't know okay so i'm at i'm at
the largo
uh i'm backstage because we're shooting
today
and then i looked over and there's a
random like
military uniform here for no reason i
don't even know what this
is what side is that for
what does that represent though what
what kind of military what is that is
that one american's ally
i don't even know i think come on i
don't know do the marines
come on stone put it on party party a
role play outfit
put it on i don't gotta put it on
a random military outfit behind her
could be anything could be for any side
size probably how about this the perfect
size
fits like a glove and it's not yours
look at that you feel powerful
yes i feel like i can i can do anything
without any repercussions boxy
as hell is a steve harvey suit harvey
went to the military
remember i wrote a bit for conan about
steve harvey suits
and that did not go well yeah i might be
giving away a concept that we're doing
oh snap son what would it take for you
to
join any sort of military organization
i don't think i could ever join the
military i don't know
can you guys i know i wouldn't because i
did
uh a tv show where i played a soldier
and then
i always get cast as the soldier who
dies immediately
it's like coward soldier number one like
guys i don't think we can do this and i
died when like you know the first part
of the show when the credits are still
rolling
like who's in the show i died at that
part
i'm black i know every black person dies
during the credits of horror movies
just 100 percent
die one like every horror movie the
credits go up and they go
what's that what
during the song during the song where
they introduce everyone
hey jack we going we going voting today
oh no no this remind me of my conan bit
the desk moving back and forth yeah look
at you look at this setup
you guys are not familiar dia cole has
been djing
disco mornings he bought all this
equipment a couple years ago
and then just in the lockdown i bought
it four years ago
and never had time to play with it and
just had it sitting up
and then when this pandemic hit i was
like
let me see if i can play this
next thing you know i start at dj
cinema records to break and all of that
so it's been going great it's been good
it's been fun
something to do keep your mind sane you
live alone
and you don't have no woman oh pets
yeah well this is what he's known for
he's the dj that cries like right before
the bass drops he
fully cries
when i first started people was busting
up laughing man it was like
don't quit your day job like everybody
cuz i was so horrible with it
but i figured you know what
if i learn how to do this in front of
these people's faces
they're gonna feel some kind of way
because you should be doing something
with your pandemic
time you should be learning a new
language writing a script
doing something you love to do and while
you're laughing at me
i'm gonna i'm gonna get better and
that's exactly what happened would you
ever do requests i know dj's
absolutely hate that nah i won't do no
requests
nah not at all coming up to the booth
grabbing on your equipment
i'm like why are you gonna come in here
and ask to request something you just
heard in the car
like
you should have it on your playlist
already why would you come in here and
want to hear it too like you love it
that much
can you play a full episode of the joe
rogan podcast
i start talking about nootropics that's
how i get
[Laughter]
me and timothy is here
and you also have your record behind you
do you ever try to work your stand up
into some disco just on the the b side i
did one day i did it one day i play the
track and i play i play my
my uh my uh comedy on the track but then
i took it off because i play every
sunday at like 11 a.m
and a lot of older people and it just
didn't go
good with disco sunday fellowship and i
was on
you see that being out sticking to now
pushing and i was
i was like yeah that ain't that ain't
that ain't the moment
this got me i know this guy baby
i need to backslide this hour
dion cole saturday night backslide
backslide
so sona has picked up kind of a
quarantined skill you picked up archery
have you kept up with that my husband
wanted to buy a gun
and i was like please don't buy a gun
and so he's like okay i'm gonna buy a
bow and arrow
and so he bought like this massive
bow and arrow and all the equipment like
the wrist guard
and the thing that you put on your back
to like pull out
arrows what is it called the uh quill
quiver i forgot quill quiver quiver
that's what it is and so uh sometimes
like we just go to our backyard and we
just
shoot bows and arrows at this bag
just enough terrible things were
happening last year that i remember when
when you when you were
you told me about this i my first
thought was not like whoa that's
whimsical it was like
that's actually smart archery it's
actually fun it sounds
fun as hell but if you're using it to
protect
you all you will be shot just
just know that know that they will shoot
you
the time it takes for him to put his
gloves
on and grab his arrows i gotta chalk my
hand
lick the arrow and line it up because i
know he licked his arrows
lick the arrow and line it up wait wait
why is attack licking the arrows he
because
that you got that's the sinister
way to do it you got to lick the arrow
before you shoot him you lick your arrow
by the time you do all of this and then
you gotta then you gotta like aim it you
gotta
get the aim he will be shot
why is he signing up to leave dna at the
scene
it's just that's just sick arrow stuff
you do man
there's arrow stuff it's cool aero stuff
man
there are there are better ways to
protect yourself from like a home
invasion
you got a robbery standing there like
this like
hey i love that rash cream in your
dressing room oh
man
[Music]
what did he say we missed a solid joke
he said i
i left that rash cream in your dressing
room
oh that's great tell us about the rash
there is no rash
he's just being an you know
matt's a pretty strong
guy he wouldn't just make something up
beyond you did
something i would never do where you put
out essentially a non-special
special uh pretty recently
on netflix's youtube channel i think
it's on where you're working out
material
for a tour for not even a special where
you're like i have a half idea to even
before you go on tour you do these small
shows
that if if anyone even listens to a
voice memo of mine i
think i would die and you put this out
it's
so funny it's hostile
you're yelling at audience members it's
incredible what
uh besides just like having nothing to
do what was the incentive behind putting
that out
i was thinking like yeah all that
material that i was working on for my
special that i chose not to use
it's still funny i was like man i wonder
i said i should put something together
so
i put together all this footage of stuff
that i was doing
um that i was working on that that i did
not choose
from for my tour or my up-and-coming
special
and i was like man i should just put
together and show the people just the
whole process
of of of how we come up with material
and how it doesn't work and how we
insecure with it and
just these nights of everything ain't
glorified
everything ain't in front of yeah three
thousand five thousand people every
night this is
40 people me trying to work this out and
show people this process you know as
well as give them something you know
that they can
you know laugh at and and have during
these pandemic times or whatever so
i put it together and netflix saw it and
they was like damn
like yeah we can definitely do this and
i was like yeah we should definitely put
it
on the youtube channel like just keep it
raw
give it to the people and they was like
let's do it and we put it out and
i think i'm like up to it's been
probably about
since october november we almost got a
million
yeah we almost haven't said it which is
crazy i i
i watched it maybe a couple of times it
was the first thing that made me really
miss performing live
because that's what it is you watch a
special someone has a bunch of purple
lights behind them and a leather shirt
they never wear
yeah that doesn't make me miss it that's
like oh yeah i feel like his agents are
backstage
but when you're in the lab you're
yelling at people this woman's like
catfish
it's uh that was the first thing that
made me miss
performing live man and news and it was
genuine you know it was a genuine it was
a genuine take all those were genuine
takes and i was like preparing for my
tour
that i was gonna go out on in april and
then when
covey hit it just it stopped all that
and i just was like damn
you know but so the the
tripped out thing is people love it and
i'm glad they love me they'd be
gravitating to it but
um they didn't they still haven't seen
what i kept so
i would love so if if if they're loving
that
that's amazing for them to see what i
kept you know out of all those nights
yeah
because also you're doing well you're
the first person i've seen do well
and am i wrong is this performed in the
improv lab
the lab yes okay so if anyone's not
familiar the improv
is like got a divorce and
mom's house is the main room it's
incredible there's food
and then the lab dad's house
it's mostly a bar there's not a lot of
people it's
sketchy people have nothing better to do
it's hostile for no reason
and you pulled off essentially a special
in the
worst room in l.a arguably
see the thing about l.a is when they
come to comedians
that's why everybody thinks they're
funny because everybody here is so
polite
and so giving that
be feeling like yo they
the funniest in the world
but you go take that to memphis
they will
murder your ass in memphis they will
throw at you that shouldn't even be
at the comedy shows and though
so you rice
like i have a wedding later
who threw cooked rice at me right
through office real
you're like who's cooking rice so i was
like man let me get let me do the lab
and and the people at the improv were so
cool man and so i was like
they was like yeah you want to work out
in the main room i was like
i mean my agent andrew was like yo yeah
you you should
you should do the lab and we was like
fine so we got up and i did and i was
like i remember those first few nights i
was like this is
not the move and then i start going
great it's not the move because
everywhere else you really ain't gonna
be able to get the real people gonna
laugh just to be
just to be generous and that that
doesn't help you
like in l.a a lot of l.a not la people
but people in
l.a they have to know that you're not
helping when you're when you're being
polite
because what you're doing is you setting
comics up for failure when they leave
l.a because it's all performers in la in
new york so everyone if it doesn't go
over people like
i'm just so happy he's expressing
himself yes
very rough day in my class i was very
vulnerable in my actions
i just appreciate his vulnerability and
then you go to phoenix with someone that
lost their job they hate their wife
they're addicted to percocet
spaghetti how come spaghetti is always
too wet and people are like
no they have a bad life no
it's a world of difference man it's
really different so
i was like i want to have one of the
hardest rooms because i figured like
this
if they give me a hard time in this room
this would be the equivalent
to me doing okay
you know what i mean so i was like yeah
i'm gonna do it
and it's and it shows in the special
when you look at
it like when people when people look at
it you
you see this is this isn't your normal
la set or audience you know this is
this is like me like soul
wrenching like riding home with no radio
you know oh a bad set and no radio home
oh i know that you're like you piece of
you don't even deserve
music
all you hear is turn signals that's it
you hear the light change
the other thing that you kept in your
special i was so happy about is you were
like why did i wear this sweater
because every time a joke doesn't go
over well you're never gonna wear
that shirt again especially if it's new
you get home and you're like just stupid
why would they
why would you cook your own food
you'll blame yourself on everything why
did i eat oatmeal before i went
i'm gonna eat no oatmeal no more pioneer
days who eats oatmeal
i'm a successful man
i am free to dj on sundays
oatmeal and cuts every sunday dior
cold playing the cuts and eating oatmeal
every sunday 11 a.m disco
oatmeal oh this is geriatric
though oh god oh god
what's happening is
ah yes
yes
how you guys doing what's up cody
how are you what you doing buddy
well you know just uh going over my
notes
whatever just grinding it out just
trying to grind it out
that's what people say nice coat
right nice geez
red berries without doing it
like a biplane in here from the truman
error
largo oh and a big old foam pouch
this gun is in here and it's creeping me
out oh my god
it's okay coleman but i gotta run i
gotta get my makeup on i'll see you guys
later all right brother have a great day
love you man love you back in there
don't tell anybody about the
ventriloquist dummy
we're ahead of you
oh my god that was horrifying i'm sorry
i was upset about how much i look like
that dummy
like it looks like the dummy i would
work out my therapy
you need to yell at you yo sona what
room are you in
there's a there's a military outfit and
a ventriloquist dummy
that's that's gotta make it on the show
yeah
lee look at that room and a troll
a weightlifting troll
the largo's known for its bodybuilding
context 1981.
sad because that means someone peaked in
81 and they're still keeping that around
[Music]
it doesn't even have a plaque they don't
even know whose it is i remember one of
my mom's boyfriends had bodybuilding
tapes and he was really proud of him
and we have to watch bodybuilding tapes
which are just a guy just going like
there's no action he's just watching a
man's nude torso
sona you've been doing um well at the
beginning you're doing sona fixes your
life
a lot of things have changed since then
you might be bringing it back have the
questions got
more serious no no no no i don't i even
if there is a serious question i'm not
equipped to answer it i'm not like a
licensed therapist and uh most of the
advice that i give is
terrible so i think that you know i
think that it's just we're going to keep
it light-hearted and fun it'll come back
eventually it's really fun to do it
has there ever been a question we were
like i can't without naming names that
you were like i can't answer this
this is true no i've answered all of
them
yeah none of them are like a lot of them
are like
what do i like what should i cook for
thanksgiving
or hey can i eat old butter like you
know
those are the questions the people is
there such thing as old butter
that's what i said and also i'm i'm in
the house where i'm like i don't even
pay
attention to the best buy or sell by
dates i go by smell
something smells weird i won't eat it
but if it's like two weeks
past the expiration date and it's fine
yeah dionne how do you feel about that
because like the best before
sell by it's all over the place it's
kind of like asking someone in la their
age
where it's just like let's just say i'm
best before june like you can't
no way to tell the dates on anything
are you guys strict with dates that's
funniest thing
i'm not i mean we are garbage growing up
now
yeah and if something in you if there's
like an almond milk and it says february
21st and you see it and it smells fine
you won't even eat you won't drink it
yeah i'm throwing that away
really because i've done it before and i
was like hell yeah whatever and i got
sick one time and after that i was like
okay i'm good
yeah it's like once you get sick
you've been you've been good so you know
you're gonna keep eating all those
expired things what about medicine do
you do the same thing with medicine
oh yeah it gets better cough syrup
robitussin gets better after the date
after the date starts to separate a
little bit it starts to curdle
oh what's this no my my parents are very
old school my mom did not give us like
medicine she just was like just tough it
out and beat it yourself
old school that's like the 1600s
you beat it out and do some bloodletting
i know so we would just suffer and then
we'd get over it so i don't even
i don't even know what medicine i have
in my house like i don't think i have
any i don't have cold syrup this is the
only medicine
a lot of family has they have like cough
syrup
and pepto-bismol and duct tape that's
that's that's all they fix anything
that's wrong
with the duct tape for my stomach hurts
swallow a little piece of duct tape
get all those toxins out it's like those
viewer strips
dip it in pulls the toxins out
guys i might have to i might have to
take off soon because we're gonna have
to do the
review i'm so sorry no no we're gonna
wrap up soon we got we got
a bunch of stuff here this has been
great okay good this is also the
internet where no one's like
can the show be longer no one on youtube
we're one of people's many open tabs
right now
we have like hardcore porn some
craigslist they're not gonna buy
some screenplay they're not gonna finish
and then we're over here talking about
archery and licking arrows
[Laughter]
sona maybe sona fixes your life is gonna
come back in the near future
i think so so send her some real heavy
questions
hard-hitting stuff i'll i'll fix
anything
and then dion has the special out slash
non-special it's on the netflix youtube
it comes up right away
you can just go to youtube go to youtube
and type in working it out working it
out on youtube
bam you'll see it it's right there and
then check me out every sunday i guess
down i guess down every sunday
at uh on um here djing
on instagram live and um i produced a
movie
that i'll probably have to come back and
talk about all that
but just real quickly what's the movie
real quickly no
it's it's it's called it's called i'm
fine thanks for asking
and uh you can go to the instagram page
and just like the page and then
once we get the movie uh it's already
shot it's done
and everything but once we um finish our
negotiations with it then
i'll let everybody know but it's called
i'm fine thanks for asking
it's a good movie me and my partner
kelly kelly and uh yeah we we
excited about it we got some other
projects too so i definitely be back to
talk to you all
yeah absolutely so go check that out and
follow that page
right now support the movie you know
trying to do your own
and dion cole on uh on instagram yes
thank you all so much this has been
great moses yeah man thanks for talking
to me the first person to talk to
today this is great love baby thank
y'all man sona thank you so much for
being
here have a great show oh thank you
today i'm sure you're gonna be in it
this is a lot of fun
we'll see you guys soon